coming into samuel l jackson as shaft
it was no different i wanted to really
embrace him as shaft 2000 and
come up with ideas that would give that
same kind of power
to sam in the character and fashion it
was also a fashion statement
well because of those leathers are much
more supple than the heart leather that
richard round she wore weren't they the
ones you put sam in
yeah with chef 2000 i'm just trying to
let you know i'm paying attention
i'm just a trained girl seeking fullness
of detail that's all i'm doing here for
you
but you dress characters oh and we can
see the swagger in them
you want us to get a sense of how these
people these these characters plant
their feet on the ground
uh and and and it's funny to say that
but i get a sense of even seeing
somebody from the shoulders up when you
costume them
what shoes they're wearing i can tell
from the way they're standing
you know there's a kind of a pride that
goes all the way down isn't there
yeah there is i think of uh eddie
um in dolomite he had to wear a lot of
platform shoes and
uh you know guys aren't wearing those
anymore so you know just the whole idea
of it was
i'm sure we laughed about it but poor
eddie
had to wear them and after a while we
had to decide what
shots were not seeing his feet so he
could put his tennis shoes back on
but he does say that the costume design
does help him give a
get get a sense of his posture and his
his gait and it does support his
performance and
to hear someone iconic like eddie murphy
say that it's wonderful